Shh hey what's up guys I'm super excited
to make this video for you just because
a lot of you guys know that I've had
eczema for my entire life ever since I
was a baby
a lot of you guys have been asking for
what kind of treatment I used and I'm
proud to say that the FDA has finally
approved the medicine that I've been
actually under a clinical trial for for
the past two years super excited to show
you it's called Duke Dixon it was
previously known as the Chilam and it's
an injection and I'll show you guys a
little bit how it works and fYI this is
not a sponsored video this is something
that has personally affected and changed
my life for the better and something I
just really want to share with you guys
so a little bit about eczema eczema is a
skin condition in which you get a lot of
rashes a lot of itchy rashes very scaly
and bumpy and it's very flaky to your
skin actually flakes off the more you
scratch it and the more you scratch of
the more irritated it get and I'll get
more red it'll start bleeding
you'll start oozing and then it's not a
pretty sight when I was a kid I used to
have it on my neck used to have it in my
like sweats land areas behind the back
of my knees but as I got older and
spread away from the glands and into
just on my arms on my legs the worst of
it all was when it reached my hands and
for some reason and really focused
almost exclusively on my hands for I
think from middle school to high school
there's no a better way to put it then
and say that I look like a burn victim
because that's exactly what it looks
like over time it's very dark and
complexion to the longer you had it
actually changes the tone of your skin
and it got so bad to the point where I
couldn't shake people's hands you know
my hands are scaly it wasn't soft and
smooth like in supposed to be a scaly
and rough and and it was always itching
all always scratching though it was so
bad on my hands that when I was driving
I realized I had a collection of dead
skin flakes at in my carbs because where
my hands would hover around the steering
wheel you know the skin would just fall
off my hands and it was so dry you know
it's disgusting and that was something I
was very embarrassed about and over time
it starts to eat at you and
kind of tears down your confidence and
what's even crazy is that it affected my
relationship with tips who have been
with for five years now and the first
couple years I pretty much tried to hide
all my symptoms from her and I couldn't
be intimate with her exist every time I
touched her you know she could sense
that my hand drew scaley you know not
only does it affect your skin but it
definitely affects your entire lifestyle
thirty years I've actually tried a lot
of different methods and different
medicine to try and remedy eczema you
know I remember when I was a kid my mom
you take me through a lot of skin
doctors they would prescribe me topical
steroids and stuff like that and they
work they work because the steroids no
they definitely work and within a week
you know you would see the eczema start
to reside but but it wears down your
skin as it healed the texture your skin
starts to thin out and actually damages
the skin even more and because it's a
steroid
it becomes very dependent on this lotion
and without it your your eczema actually
comes back ten times worse so that
didn't work later on in my years I
started turning toward Eastern medicine
like Chinese herbal remedies I went to
this acupuncturist and you know put
needles in me and try to release the
poisons and stuff like that and under
that stuff really work now eczema it's
weird because it likes to travel around
your body it doesn't never stick in one
place but eventually I started traveling
up to my face and that was when I
realized I really needed to find help
the grew up around my eyes I look like a
panda after a while with red spots
around my eyes because this is so bad my
hands got even worse too and it got to
the point where I couldn't even close my
hands like I couldn't do this doing this
was a luxury about three years ago and I
couldn't do this without something
cracking like my skin was literally
crack and I could feel it first open so
what's all that stuff it made it really
hard to work you know because I and I
make videos for a living
and I need is be I need to be in front
of the camera and I can't be having
rashes on my face like that and then my
hands I need my hands to move things to
pick up the camera too you know to do
things and I couldn't do that and I
couldn't be intimate with people and
kind of shake people's hands without
feeling like I was some sort of creature
so luckily though I had a friend of mine
who introduced me to a new research that
was happening about three years ago and
they were running tests on a drug called
do pill mmm
that's the generic name for this
medicine so diplomat is basically a an
antibody that you inject into yourself
and it clings on to certain proteins
inside your body and it shuts down the
very thing that creates eczema before
with the topical steroids and all these
other remedies there was a lot of side
effects because there wasn't a direct
target of that medicine but for
depictions it is a direct target go
straight to the very source of the
problem it took them many years to
figure it out but I'm glad that they
figured it up now when I heard about
this it was too good to be true I
actually was very skeptical and in fact
there's one of those things where we a
man might or might work for some people
but will it work for me it might be that
guy at the great breakthrough for the
thing I have doesn't apply to me because
I'm that unlucky guy that just has a
very severe case of it yeah I was really
nervous going into this study program
just because you know it's a new
medicine no one is really too sure what
the side effects are and that's why they
have this clinical trial but you know at
the end of the day though I rather not
live with hell you know I'd rather not
have all these things happening you know
if it took a leap of faith in this new
medicine then you know that was
something I was gonna have to do and
even if it wasn't going to help me I
thought at least it's worth of trust
within the first month it was less itchy
less red more just kind of paint still
dry skin still there but I think it took
a full three months for me personally
and for everything to kind of go away I
was in this clinical trial for two years
so that means for majority of this
clinical trial I kept going back there
as a patient but I didn't even look like
a patient
I looked cured you know and they would
always show up at me
and like to you and be a part of this
and important you know it's a miracle
drug this this drug really worked really
well for me there were no side effects
and there was a very painless experience
you know I mean the only thing that you
have to get over is fact they get to
inject yourself I think that took me one
time to really just kind of poke myself
to kind of get that initial fear out of
the way another oh this is what it is
okay not so bad and the rest is history
alright so I'm going to show you guys
how I use depicts it now I'm actually
really proud of this because the shots I
received during the ton of trials where
this like bootleg looking needle a
syringe but now it comes in a nice
little fancy box like this which is
pretty cool because this is a really big
step up from what I got and it's all
branded to now that's pretty cool and
that's what it looks like very fancy
syringe actually it's got this nice
plastic casing around it and so I will
show you guys how I am checked myself
alcohol white always have an alcohol
white and cotton ball so usually I'm
going to go for the belly you want to
inject somewhere that's got a nice chunk
of fat so the belly would be a pretty
nice fatty area to do this take this off
you want to pinch your skin get a nice
chunk of fat here
and then go in and then you inject into
really thick serum so it takes a while
oh cool just going to dab it and then
you're done but this is very cool this
is surprising because you inject it once
you release with spring offere releases
and it pushes the the syringe out for
you that was really cool and now it's
safe now you will never poke yourself
that's pretty cool and that's it so
simple this medicine really works I mean
my hands didn't look like this three
years ago you know this was a mess three
years ago you know my mom she's worked
endlessly tirelessly throughout my
childhood to try and find remedies for
this and to be a part of this trial and
to be a part of this development in
others new medicine that cures the very
thing that's plagued me my entire life I
mean it come full circle and that's just
a beautiful thing in itself and I
couldn't be more honored to have been a
part of something like this and I just
want to get the word out there again
it's not a sponsored video I just want
to share my journey with eczema with you
guys I wish I actually documented
everything I think I was too shy and too
embarrassed too ashamed of eczema to
really have taking any pictures or video
of it generally I didn't document
anything but now with this result I wish
I had you know so I had something more
you know substantial to show you guys so
if you guys want to learn more about
your pixon aka - pillow map check out
good pic centcom check it out you know
hopefully you know this video was of
some help for anyone that has eczema or
if you know anyone that has eczema do
share this video and let him know about
do Pyxis I thank guys
[Music]